empezó a las 8 de la noche en punto de
washington y la primera en hablar fue la
representante de la cámara de lisa jane
y ella es de wyoming ella es una de las
dos republicanas que hace parte del
comité que investiga lo que pasó el 6 de
enero del 2021 una de las dos únicos
republicanos que hace parte de este
comité ella dijo que básicamente las
pruebas que se están presentando
muestran que trump estuvo en el centro
de los esfuerzos para desconocer los
resultados de las elecciones
presidenciales pasadas dio y puso vídeos
de republicanos de familiares y de
allegados al gobierno y asesores y
personas que hicieron parte del gobierno
de donald trump ellos mismos diciendo
como no había pruebas suficientes para
desconocer los resultados electorales de
las elecciones del 2020 entre los que
pusieron en vídeo estuvo el fiscal el ex
fiscal general william ward que decía en
repetidas ocasiones que le dijo al
presidente trump que no había pruebas
suficientes
su hija ivanka trump estuvo también en
vídeo en estas pruebas que está
presentando lister y diciendo que
efectivamente ha apoyado al fiscal
general y otros otros asesores más
también diciendo que no había pruebas
para el argumento de fraude electoral
cristóbal justamente uno de los puntos a
determinar en estas audiencias es la
responsabilidad o no del presidente del
ex presidente de donald trump en estos
hechos qué posibilidades reales hay de
que el ex mandatario sea declarado
culpable
pues se dice que están presentando y que
van a presentar vídeos que nunca antes
se han visto pruebas que nunca antes se
habían revelado y que en total se
calcula que serán cerca de 8 audiencias
donde se presentarán todo tipo de
argumentos para probar precisamente la
responsabilidad del otro pero al final
será el departamento de justicia el que
termine tomando una acción legal frente
al ex presidente lo que puede hacer la
cámara de representantes y el congreso
simplemente es presentar toda la
evidencia que ha recogido por más de un
año